وتضحياتهن لاجله. ويستمر الحديث
عن العقيد من كارهيه قبل محبيه.
اما لطفلين وكان زوجها دبلوماسيا
حينها. سلمة اضافت ان الخطوة
للزعيم الليبي الراحل معمر
القذافي. هناك تحدثت وقالت لم
مؤخرا ظهرت حارسة اخرى من
مرافقات القذافي. سبعة وثلاثون
الفين واثني عشر نشرت صحيفة
الايطالية تحقيقا خلصت فيه الى
انذاك نيكولا ساركوزي وهو ذات
الامر الذي اكده رئيس المجلس
فقد وعيه عند اصابته بشظية في
ظهره. ولا يعرف كيفية وفاة
القذافي. لكن قبل ذلك وبتاريخ
التاسع والعشرين من سبتمبر عام
القذافي وحتى مهاجم الناتو
للموكب وهرب بعدها القذافي مشيا
من خلال فحص الحمض النووي
للجثمان قالت هذا غير صحيح.
عنها. فما هي هذه المفاجأة؟ في
المقابل منصور ضو القائد السابق
الليبي واقفا مكانه في دوامة لم
يخرج منها بعد فهل يعود العقيد
بعض اقاربه. وتم اخفاء مكان دفنه
خوفا ان يصبح القبر ضريحا يقصده
عاما هي الفترة التي رافقت بها
هذه الحارسة العقيد في جولاته
دفن العقيد بعد اربعة ايام من
مقتله ودفن الى جانبه نجله
واطلقوا عليه الرصاص الحي ومثلوا
بجثته. وكانت حالة جثة العقيد
يقتله المحتجون وخاطبهم بصفتهم
اولاده. لكن احدا لم يصغي لطلبه
ايضا خرج مسؤولون حكومة الليبية
بتصريحات ان العقيد طلب الا
تسلل الى كتائب الثوار لقتل
العقيد القذافي. في ذلك الوقت
اكثر من عشرة اعوام تغير الخبر.
فما الذي يحدث يا ترى? في مقابلة
تليفزيونية قالت الضابطة السابقة
في طاقم حراسة الرئيس الليبي
الله. في المقابلة ذاتها جاءت
بدليل على ان القذافي لم يمت عام
ان القذافي لقي مصرعه على يد
جاسوس ارسله الرئيس الفرنسي
لي حميد ابومنيار القذافي في
اشارة منها الى ان هذا الضابط
عن ان محكمة الجنايات الدولية
اكدت ان المقتول هو القذافي وذلك
لكن ما يتمناه الليبيون هو ان
يكون العقيد على قيد الحياة بعد
بعودة العقيد ومتشائم بان موته
قد عفا عليه الزمن يظل الشعب
القذافي حين قامت الاحتجاجات
وخرج من البلاد عندما سألوه
يا عائشة؟ البيتور تجيب بقولها
سيدي القائد لم يدخل مدينة سرت
شعرن الخطر على الثورة والقائد
بحسب ما قالت. الجميع كان يتدرب
يكن يطلب الحارسة لمرافقته بل كن
يتطوعن من تلقاء انفسهن. هذه
المعتصم ووزير دفاعه السابق ابو
بكر يونس بحسب تلك التصريحات.
تقارير تؤكد ذلك فهل لا يزال
العقيد حيا يرزق؟ وبين متفائل
حقا؟ ام ان عودة العقيد هي تسلم
ابنه سيف الاسلام للسلطة؟ ستكون
الابراج. حديث سالمة يوضح اكثر
مدى حب الحارسات للعقيد ولثورته
على تفكيك وتركيب السلاح.
بالاضافة للرماية والقفز من
الانتقالي وقتل لاحقا في ظروف لا
تزال تفاصيلها ضبابية. وقال انه
اشاعات فهل نجح الغرب في مخططهم
وقتلوا القذافي حقا؟ بدا القذافي
في تلك الصور وهو يستعطف شبانا
فيما يشبه محاولات يائسة لتجنب
جاءت بعدما اسست هي ورفيقتها
عائشة تشكيلا ثوريا نسائيا عندما
على الاقدام عبر انبوب مجاري حيث
قبض عليه مقاتلو المجلس الوطني
المتحللة قد اجبرت المسؤولين على
اصدار قرار دفنه. لكن سرا وبحضور
المرافقة نفت ان القذافي كان
يفضل الحارسات العازبات فهي كانت
داخليا وخارجيا وهي سالمة
عبدالله الحارسة الشخصية الاولى
الانتقالي الليبي ساعتها محمود
جبريل مشيرا الى ان عميلا اجنبيا
اللحظات الاخيرة للقذافي. رحلة
فرارهم الفوضوية من مسقط رأس
بعدها عاصفة اعلامية متخبطة بين
مصدقة للخبر ومكذبة. لكن بعد
على عقب. فهل ينتظر الشعب الليبي
ظهور العقيد مجددا? عائشة
للحرس الثوري الليبي الذي يعرف
بانه الصندوق الاسود لبعض احلك
على حاله والسر لم يكشف ولا يبدو
انه في طريقه للانكشاف. لتهب
العقيد. قاتل العقيد ولم يفر من
المعركة لكن تمر السنين وتنتشر
العرب معه ضد امريكا وبريطانيا
واسرائيل. لكن عكس ذلك هو ما حصل
لم يتم تسليم الجثمان? لتقلب
الفيتوري الوسط الاعلامي رأسا
اسرار ليبيا وخبايا نظام الزعيم
الليبي معمر القذافي يقول عن
فلماذا لم يصدر قرار من الامم
المتحدة بذلك حتى الان? ولماذا
يعلم ان الذي قتل هو حميد وليس
الزعيم الليبي. وعندما سئلت في
لماذا لم ترجع الى ليبيا حتى
الان قال لهم ساعود اذا اظهرتم
الفين واحد عشر ان احد الضباط
البارزين الذين انشقوا عن
الفيتوري تحدثت عن مفاجأة قادمة
للشعب الليبي لكنها لم تفصح
يدري ما الذي يخبي القدر. حاول
العقيد ان يصل لاهدافه باستمالة
بل حميد ابو منيار القذافي الذي
شبه لهم انه هو. سيدي القائد دخل
مرافقات القذافي وعن حياته؟ فهل
يظهر العقيد مجددا بعد اكثر من
مصيره المحتوم الذي اظهرته لاحقا
صور متعاقبة التقطها هواة ليتم
اعلان مقتله رسميا من دون رواية
نهائية لظروف ذلك وما زال الوضع
يقولها الليبيون فجأة تخرج احدى
حارساته الشخصية. وتقول العقيد
مدينة بني وليد شمالا ومن ثم
غادرها. اطمئن الشعب بان سيدي
القائد بخير ويقود المقاومة وهو
على رأس الزحف المقدس بقدرة
يزال على قيد الحياة. وان الذي
هو احد اقاربه. اذا فمن الذي مات
الناس يترحمون على القذافي. وشعب
ليبيا يندب حظه لوفاة العقيد.
الراحل معمر القذافي عائشة
الفيتوري. ان الزعيم الليبي لا
الايام القادمة كفيلة بالايضاح.
ذلك حقيقة فمن هو الذي قتل وتم
اظهاره؟ على انه العقيد ما الذي
سنوات مرت وليبيا تمر باسوأ
الاوضاع. اين انت ايها العقيد؟
دولية. وقد امتدت تلك العزلة لما
هو اكبر وتدخل الغرب لمحاولة قتل
فقد حصل الغرب على دعم من القادة
العرب ليجعل ليبيا في عزلة
يجري في ليبيا يا سادة؟ تخرج
حارسة اخرى للعقيد وتتحدث عن
عشر سنوات على اختفائه؟ هل يعود
ليرى ما الذي الت اليه ليبيا من
لا يزال حيا وهو يقود المقاومة.
ايعقل هذا؟ ولماذا اختبأ العقيد
كل هذه المدة؟ وهل تشهد الايام
القادمة عودة القذافي لكن ان كان